[Musique]
monsieur marche tout le monde dit que
vous êtes dingue et méchant c'est
vrai et pourquoi faut-il qu'il fasse
autant de boucans Harry désolé plus il
en a plus il en veut un voisin qui est
bruyant et quiffant vos oreilles la BAM
je sais pas quel projet fou se tramee
dans ton cerveau promets-moi e que tu
feras rien de
stup tu vas vraiment aller au dîner de
Monsieur la sérieusement je vais
l'annuler on est en
mission je veux que vous me donz vos
cheveux sérieux le plan prévoit du
crcheval vous AZ vraiment l'air de bien
l'imer j'en prendrai elle voulait
protéger les B
c'est vous le CIN de cheval ou vous
l'avez
reçu pour tout ce que vous voulez savoir
sur le 20e siècle destructeur sans
esprit vous pourz vous tourner vers
la pasre de discours tu sais que es
vraiment fatigant on est tous les
deuxtigant ma femme écr on ESP que vous
puissiez l
son je pour mais je
pasarve deç
les de toi-même vous êtes pas un homme
du 18e siècle vous agissez comme un taré
vous parlez à Hector si seulement il
[Musique]
savait tenez bon Henry la fin approche
comme si j'avais besoin qu'on me le
rappelle vous avez été merveilleux je
suis là jusqu'à la fin du monde